a war on Europe's doorstep
a full-scale invasion of a Sovereign
Nation peace on our continent has been
shattered President Putin launched the
greatest threat to European stability
since World War II and now he and his
country will bear the consequence
as Russian tanks rolled in many believed
it would be over in days Russia's
president warning Ukraine's allies to
back off you will face consequences
greater than any you have faced in
history he said but Vladimir Putin
underestimated the resistance ukrainians
arming themselves
defiant courageous
and their president standing his ground
in the Capitol
This Is Our Land our country our
children Vladimir zielinski says and we
will defend all of it one year later
there remains no end in sight to
Russia's war in Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
when Russian tanks first rolled in a
year ago it was feared it would be over
in days and yet here we are it is clear
Ukraine and its people supported by
allies have defied Vladimir Putin what's
less clear is what happens next how does
this war the largest military conflict
in Europe since the end of the second
World War end the United Nations
estimates there have been more than 21
200 civilian casualties in Ukraine since
the War Began mostly from heavy shelling
missiles and airstrikes more than 8 000
people have been killed more than 13 000
injured Russian forces have taken
territory but face humiliating setbacks
and massive losses what started as a
full-scale attack has ground down to a
steady brutal fight along the Eastern
Front Line the Kremlin controls part of
her son and the South and zaparisia
including Europe's largest nuclear power
plant plus nearly all of luhansk and
more than half of Donetsk and Russia
keeps launching Relentless attacks using
missiles and drones targeting Ukraine's
infrastructure and cities what Russia
failed to recognize is the resilience
and the strength of the Ukrainian people
for one long year that resistance has
stood strong her son was the first large
city the only Regional Capital to fall
into Russian control ukrainians fought
back they won the city back but there's
still no peace Jeff simple went to her
song to find out what drives the people
there to carry on
Russia's invasion of Ukraine isn't is
going as planned but capturing her son
was perhaps the kremlin's most
significant victory
on March 2nd the Russian military took
control of the southern city and
Vladimir Putin claimed it would remain
part of Russia forever but Lilia
alexandrova had other plans
the stay-at-home mother of three doesn't
look like your stereotypical resistance
leader but that may have helped her
evade detection Russian Vehicles
patrolled the street outside her
apartment but after dark she would sneak
out armed with a can of spray paint
there you go Ukrainian flag
alexandrova secretly painted Ukrainian
flags all around her Russian occupied
neighborhood
my hands were shaking and my heart was
pounding I was so nervous she says but I
knew that God would protect us because I
was doing the right thing when the
Russians covered up her work she would
make her Mark again and again and again
you're very brave
and courage can be contagious before
long she started seeing markings from
others one of the most common symbols a
yellow ribbon
the yellow ribbon United us and showed
that we were against the Russians and
that we were waiting for the Armed
Forces of Ukraine to liberate our city
she says but what began as a silent
largely symbolic protest quickly evolved
into a full-blown underground resistance
yellow ribbon it's a
biggest movement Alex whose identity
we're protecting is an I.T worker turned
civil resistance leader in the first
weeks of the occupation he says they
organized secret meetings and even
anti-russian protests
[Music]
okay
provoking a fierce Crackdown from the
Russian occupiers one protester a woman
in her 70s was killed other activists
were arrested Alex says their
whereabouts are still unknown
we showed the Russians that the
Ukrainian people are against them he
says and the way the Russians responded
showed us that they were afraid
this activist in Odessa a few hours West
organized secret evacuations to get
women and children out of her son their
buses forced to cross dozens of Russian
checkpoints it was real nightmare
because any any time they could stop you
they could rob you and they could they
could send you back we were lucky that
they didn't check out thoroughly and
they just let us through but eventually
he says the Russians confiscated some of
their buses while another was hit by
shelling and after that all our creation
stopped
meanwhile as Russia was holding sham
referendums on annexation in her son and
other occupied territories yellow ribbon
members were secretly sending
information about Russian activities and
positions to the Ukrainian military
I collected as much information and
photos as possible piece by piece and
then sent them the coordinates
alexandrova says then in November after
eight months under occupation the day
she'd been praying for finally came
her son was liberated the Russians were
treating a few kilometers across the
river sparking celebrations in the
streets and the yellow ribbon movement
isn't done yet it now counts more than
four thousand members applying hard
learned lessons to other occupied
territories in Ukraine hoping for a
similar outcome
the Russians don't belong here she says
her son is Ukraine
at the start of the invasion there were
negotiations and talk of a potential
diplomatic resolution all of that is
faded away both countries have already
suffered extraordinary losses no one
knows for sure just how many but U.S and
European officials estimate a hundred
and eighty thousand Russian troops more
than one hundred thousand Ukrainian
troops have been killed or wounded dark
clouds hang over the life and death
struggle as it descends into a second
year and the question lingers how and
when will it stop Eric Sorensen looks at
Russia's end game
as Vladimir Putin formally recognized
the annexation of Ukraine's four Eastern
provinces it suggested a fat accompli
the new territories were his
it also suggested his original aims had
been abandoned
to demilitarize and demossify Ukraine
Putin declared a year ago meant taking
control of the entire country it didn't
happen
Putin overestimated Russian military
capabilities he underestimated the
Ukrainian resistance the country's
leader Valor zelenski and NATO's resolve
one year later Putin has reshaped the
mission and the message the goal now to
defend the Fatherland against the entire
West Putin at the moment is is has no
intention to capitulate in fact he
thinks that he can still win this war
and he still controls what Russians know
of the war
public dissent visible a year ago has
been largely suppressed military losses
are evident in local funerals but the
death toll is played down the media
message is almost universally pro-putin
this recruit is ready to fight
I'm a simple man he said if I'm told to
go I'll go
nothing to fear he said as he walked
away
[Applause]
Putin's call to national pride strikes a
chord with Russians
you listen to him and you believe we're
on the right path she says he's like a
father to us
strong stable uh 83 percent is
moscow-based pollster says support for
Putin has not wavered and Russians are
responding to his patriotic message it
helps them to understand their country
as a fighter against some kind of
Eternal evil there's evidence that
Vladimir Putin's grand plan is to bring
Ukraine Belarus and other former Soviet
States back under moscow's control in a
greater Russia but the Baltic states are
all now in NATO and NATO's perimeter
with Russia is about to extend all the
way to Northern Finland and in Ukraine
Putin seems to have underestimated one
more thing the difficulty for Russia to
hold its Annex territories the front
lines are all inside those four Eastern
provinces it's here that Russia's new
offensive is underway it has more
military hardware than Ukraine air
superiority drones from Iran and up to
three hundred thousand new recruits but
Ukraine is getting more backing from
NATO countries including drones leopard
tanks howitzers and armored personnel
carriers from Canada
so now what potentially a long and
bloody stalemate
it's likely to cost thousands more lives
which Russia seems willing to accept and
Ukraine will sacrifice in its defense
stalemate that leads to a ceasefire
might be enough for Putin
with a land Corridor to Crimea and
conquered territory says Russian scholar
Dmitry oreshken Russia could declare its
task complete but Ukraine does not and
may never accept that it seems like
we're nowhere near the end of this year
you shouldn't underestimate the the
Russians will to fight any movement the
Russians should have underestimated
Ukrainian wealth effect
Ukraine's unwavering commitment to fight
for all of its territory does back Putin
into a corner having started the
conflict the Russian president cannot
come away politically with nothing to
show for it and so he rallies support
for a war that for now he can neither
win nor end
I hope I go back for the celebration
that would be an amazing story
coming up powerful personal perspectives
from global
foreign
[Music]
the Pulitzer Prize for journalism in
2022 is awarded to the journalists of
Ukraine who despite bombardment
abductions occupation even death within
their ranks persisted Global News has
had teams in Ukraine too and here are
some of their experiences in their own
words
one of the painful things about going
back in 2022 was that we weren't able to
go and visit the areas of Ukraine we had
visited in 2014. people in Ukraine are
very quick to correct you if you say oh
the war that just started they'll say no
no the war's been going on since 2014.
once you've done it once or twice you
know what to expect but in a lot of ways
it's it's harder because
um you know the grief and the horror of
what's been happening there has just
been building for a year
it was hard not to be struck by these
people who were moving out of danger
going somewhere they just literally
didn't know where
it was just Mother after Mother with
their kids and you're just like
these kids likely won't be their father
again and she won't see her husband
I remember the platform of the of the
train station being so packed with
people it was difficult to move we found
a woman and talked to her and she had
some a couple kids with her
she was trying to get onto the train she
was able to sit by a window and look at
her husband and and kind of give the
goodbyes and the hands up on the window
and I tried not to let these stories
affect me too much but this one did
in butcha we were there
not too long after they had exhumed the
bodies from from the grounds of the
church
everything was just quiet except for the
crows calling in the trees
and every so every so often you would
hear
someone breaking down because
they had found their loved one or
or hadn't found their loved one there's
so much work being done to to try to
figure out the identities of of the
remains but you have that moment to
think
can I show this
and in the end we decided you know yeah
because this is what they were dealing
with
hearing the air raid sirens for the
first time that really hits you it's a
feeling I've never experienced before
and then
when it was time to actually enter you
know the front line cities
and you can hear the artillery blasts
going off everything was sort of an
impact to me especially when we went to
do this interview
uh on this family where this
the couple's child got shot as a parrot
of two kids I can't imagine what it's
like to lose a daughter and they told me
that their lives would never be the same
and
you felt that
you feel really helpless because you
want to be a human but also you're there
to document the tragedy of the situation
so you have to kind of take a step back
and do your job you kind of realize that
that's what this is really all about
it's about heartbroken families that are
that are suffering the consequences of
one man's decision to invade and plunder
his neighbors
this entire war is based on
disinformation right the justification
for this war that Putin has said right
from the beginning is that Ukraine isn't
even really a country we're ready to
fight for our families
we went to many russian-speaking cities
and communities in Ukraine
um these communities that Putin claims
to be liberating and what we found were
people who yes speak Russian and had you
know very close Affinity to Russia who
are learning to use kalashnikovs now to
kill Russian soldiers to defend their
home because they hate Russia now
ahead finding safety in Canada
life is in limbo for millions of
ukrainians who have fled the war more
than 8 million people have crossed into
neighboring countries more than 167
thousand ukrainians have come to Canada
fleeing War means living with anxiety
and uncertainty every day as nithu
garcha explains
it's been almost a year since Yulia a
creamenka and her son Maxime saw the
five-year-old's father and grandparents
in person it was a March third when my
husband
uh told me [__] up please you need to
wake up and you need to leave the
country after more than a week spent
Sheltering underground her husband
wasn't allowed to leave it was like bomb
bomb bomb all the time and we didn't
know what to do sir he now works from
home and they check in every day
Julia says her son who witnessed the
brutal shelling is always asking
questions about when the war will end we
need to wait and curve and we will see
our my husband and his father
thank my parents
they arrived to Canada in May Julia a
florist in Ukraine got a job at a
Winnipeg flower shop and her son is
getting ready to start kindergarten
in Burnaby BC Natalia Mata reads with
her daughter as her son naps the mother
of two shares a similar story do we
believe it stopped after a few days as a
building manager in Ukraine she arranged
an underground bunker many people
came in basement with dogs with cats
with blankets with food with water she
needed to flee leaving her husband
behind
we separate he live and do it
the mother of two says they arrived to
Canada in June stranger saw her
desperate Appeal on Facebook and hosted
them for two months they now have their
own apartment filled with donated
Furniture
hey hi good to see you and clothing
thank you you're welcome from my
daughter yes I was lucky because all my
way I need a good people we started
communicating on Facebook and then you
know she ended up being right near me
and we both have nine-year-olds another
Facebook connection led to Natalya's new
job as an accountant and new friends
they helped me out so much
back in Winnipeg Yulia has found a way
to bring light into the lives of
Ukrainian mothers
through her initiative called the Colo
project where they can earn money by
selling their Creations one day changed
our lives something like we walk up and
the war started and we didn't know
anything about this and we need to go
both mothers say the kindness and
support they've received brings them
hope as they look back on a year of war
and forward to reuniting with their
loved ones
next leadership in war the man who has
come to Define Ukrainian resistance
many factors decide the outcome of
military conflicts but leadership is
often the most important
seemed Unthinkable Ukraine's president
strolling through Kiev with the American
president ignoring the air raid sirens
defiant in the face of Vladimir Putin's
attempt to wipe Ukraine off the map
president zielinski is the most pivotal
political player on the planet he is at
the very front line between Democratic
elected governments and totalitarian
regime
the moment The full-scale Invasion began
the man Russia hoped to capture or kill
sent a message to the world
we are all here protecting our
independence zelenski proclaimed from
the street a proof of Life video that
set the tone for his leadership he
realizes how important it is to match
action with words he sets such a high
moral standard the man who once played
the president in a TV drama center stage
in a real life and death struggle that
has no script
all our training makes him an effective
Communicator so he does not sugarcoat
the bad news he doesn't overdo it he's
clear direct he doesn't promise what he
can't deliver he tells it like it is
even the way zelenski dresses sends a
message whether in The Soaring arches of
London's Westminster hall meeting the
king at Buckingham Palace or addressing
the U.S Congress Ukraine didn't fall
Ukraine is alive
and kicking it's army green and cargo
pants there is no question why he's here
it's all about the war because this is
an important fight for for everybody and
it's in your interest to do this stop
Russia now or the next somebody will be
the next one to go as bombs fall and the
war drags on he never reveals even a
hint he may be losing hope it is
important for us as Leaders of Nations
to resist despair resist despair even in
the face of unspeakable Horrors he's
very Churchill he was out on the streets
after the bombardment he spoke regularly
on the radio and he also worked hard at
trying to get the rest of the world to
come on side I think this is a great
time for people of the world to see how
one individual can hold the line and
change the course of history
I am Donna Friesen thanks for watching
[Music]